Harry Jack nation
I'm Greg Alva this is Megan McNulty she
was one of my acting teachers when I was
an acting class and we've recently
reconnected because she has a YouTube
channel Naidu which is very different
although we have a lot of parents who
watch our channel so I was like sure
come on come on the channel like your
channel not quite it's more
family-friendly it's called the tiny
tutor there's a place for parents to
find tricks tools and strategies for
early reading and math development from
a tiny mama she is three foot five shut
up it was also a season private tutor
I've actually saw a couple of videos
it's very adorable stuff there were
things I learned like phonics if you
need to learn how to read again she's
very charming human being - I found it
just before you showed up
General Hospital How I Met Your Mother I
know all these things seems Franco with
a gun to my head no biggie no biggie
speaking of guns to your head there's
this trailer out called Hotel Artemus
okay red band trailer meaning it's
r-rated just like your channel just take
my heart our stuff it's about like a
hotel for assassins to hide out at or
recover at take my daughter there
[Music]
is a secret hospital for criminals
now therefore are you memberships we're
off to the races I'm in position to
finish the job for the convenience
that's a real allocation put your dirty
boots on the snow plan your own else
oh hey go [ __ ] yourself you need to
leave here right [ __ ] now
[Music]
the wolf king of LA such a dumb thing I
guess my ballroom days are over baby
this hospital ways don't trust if it was
people don't always do it their child
don't do an integration well just give
the [ __ ] alone the water in LA but it's
raining [ __ ] in here feel like we
got chemistry
[Music]
[Music]
don't you pull my pack okay if you do
I'm gonna [ __ ] you for real this time
that's one hell of a caster
am I tired oh you know I'm a parent I
don't see a lot of mood I don't get out
a lot and like I don't gonna see these
kind of me it looks like a fun movie
yeah look I can't tell you what it's
about but that's okay
it's kind of a not too distant future
Assasin's gonna come out and have a
hideout in I like that like you know the
cliche set up of the characters you got
the nurse the bank robber the contract
killer the wolf King sounds like he's
the bad guy the Jeff : caring and he's
raising a shitstorm here and the cast
looks really cool to me - I think this
sofia boutella chick is she's badass you
she always plays this character in every
movie I see those well but that's but
you you that's what you want it's cool
it's sterling K Brown you play this
badass assess with him who is an
obsessed with him who is one of the best
actors around and I saw my own yeah just
makes your heart and as an I am an MMA
fighter too so I'm worried was that like
her flip oh yeah your MMA fighter I'm a
brown belt red straight so any time a
chick is doing stuff like that I'm in
see you can identify the tiny tutor
can't identify
I'm recalled you Megan anymore tiny
tutor right here Charlie day though I
don't really buy him I love it's always
sunny in philadelphia I do I think
that's all I like and I love that show
but that's all I like them in you're a
big toned guy it takes you out a little
bit you know it's kind of distracting
these people are kind of walking all
over him in this trailer but he never
plays this kind of like top dog role in
any capacity it's and it's it's hard to
buy his accent is a little distracting
to me it seems like he's acting as an
acting teacher I don't call myself an
acting teacher cuz I hate when people
act yeah it's a little too intentional
it's to just yeah I'm like I see what
you're doing I don't know if it's just
the trailer maybe in the context of the
movie dave bautista though after being
in like guardians of the galaxy and he's
like Blade Runner 2049 this role I
thought it was it might just be another
quiet dude who says tough stuff from a
fighter turned actor he seems like
really believable in the end like that
is actual delivery
this guy's evolved into a really good
actor yeah that was my favorite moment I
love that he just stood there quietly
yeah
this is something you would see
something you would take your
seven-year-old daughter to go so he
would judge how accurate the action is
and all the gunplay but that you know
then we wouldn't want to see if it was
because it might be boring that's true
but I like the sci-fi world to it I like
that the sci-fi doesn't seem like too
big that's actually the thing I like to
do because everything is so futuristic
right now and everything is so dystopian
yeah so it's nice when you can't quite
tell like you said kind of ambiguous me
it's like they have a laser repairing
stuff you know they have like these guns
that look a little futuristic but it's
not like overblown to the point where
it's distracting it feels still
realistic and contain for movies like
this I'm more curious with the overall
tone of it is gonna be is the pacing
gonna be good is it humor gonna work
well yes in the trailer but isn't gonna
work in the movie yeah exactly like the
humor can play a big part and what makes
Charlie Days performance work everyone
else seems legit tough whereas Charlie
Day is he's an odd and distracting she's
in it to me yeah I'm so excited to see
the movie this looks like my kind of
film yeah I like a good action movie you
do cuz in real life I am an action hero
you are saving my ass left and right
never protect another human being not my
style you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Belka subscribe buttons don't work
that's another tip for you tell people
to click notification visit hey guys
more importantly check out Megan on her
YouTube channel
the tiny to my daughter show her some
support check around on Instagram and
Twitter she has her own personal
Instagram as well links in the
description box it's worth your time
it's worth my time makes everyone happy
so do it do it